were you a gamer growing up
yeah obviously she played maplestory
you're a gamer i played other games in
maple syrup what other games did you
play dory fly for fun
what the hell was that [ __ ] is that
it's a like you learn to fly in the game
and
what it's like maple story but then you
can level up your flying abilities
you know so it's a makeup story
expansion pack what what console is this
song it's on pc
i played a lot of pc you ever
yeah i do i own all of what's your
favorite console game console games
what's your favorite console
playstation probably which one one two
three four well two i really like the
lord of the rings games king arthur
good games a lot of the rings games on
ps2 yeah they're very good yeah they're
pretty good i played them in like
quite a bit quite a bit but you're more
of a anime person right obviously you
you don't get an anime into this car
i'm
sorry i'm sorry you trying to bring a
gaming into this
like the dichotomy of man so you're a
gamer well let me let me do the middle
ground then did you play any like anime
games anime isn't maplestory an anime
game
that's more like a game that has anime
aesthetic but it's not like what is like
visual novel type games right oh gosh i
played hakko shin like the dating
simulation oh yeah
yeah of course you did that's
how the [ __ ] did the body pillow
addiction start how did that side of you
start at all right
i don't know i like pillows i like
you i don't know i like pillows
there's a big difference between liking
a good pillow and a body pillow yeah
okay like i was obsessed with 2d i
didn't really like
people like male species just kidding
just kidding wow wow
sorry guys i just rich from you coming
from youtube very sorry
i wasn't attracted to like
real people human
you want into 3d
yeah yeah you can just say that you want
it for 3d like
and the way the 2d characters look were
just so pretty and i needed something
lifelike because what was the first like
anime or whatever that got you into the
2d world yeah that made you give up on
humanity yeah it makes you reject
humanity
oh the students
give me police force pull back to your
mailings 3x3 yeah don't watch that clip
yeah oh it's just the exposure of their
chest
and yeah now you're like allergic to
nipple
because it's 3d reports oh because it's
3d mark they always sense
that's right that's right yeah that's
that's that's why she can't see real
nipple because in anime yeah nipples
just don't exist
for some reason yeah you're right
any of you guys come to my house or
maybe i'll bring a pillow or something
here um the naked ones yeah they don't
have the nipples why is this did they do
that on purpose or is that how you learn
i should probably explain melanin is
scared of male nipples yeah yeah oh yeah
we're making
a sec apart from her husband melin is
like terrified of like male nipples no
it's because you know when you don't
want to stare at something but then you
just end up looking
and then
hold on
wait
continue feel like it's staring into my
soul and i just feel uncomfortable
oh sorry in other words in other words
you don't stare at the nipple the nipple
stares you back
and you don't have that eye contact
oh my god your husband was 2d like
yeah does your husband have nipples wait
wait wait
wait wait wait no no no
no
like my 2d i would have husband
boyfriend ex-boyfriend drinking
does your husband feel intimidated by
all of your body pillows no he says
something really weird wait never mind
forget it
like you can go you can't you can't just
see yourself like that oh my god come on
he can't it's a vibe no yeah it's pretty
bad
he says weird stuff a lot yeah he does
that
i feel like some of it rubs on to you
because like you're saying something
super weird when we're just doing like
the most normal thing sometimes yeah and
i'm like that didn't come from you
can i tell them what he said about
drinking water that's like what no okay
oh when you see like anime characters
drinking water oh okay there's this
character i used to like are you talking
about the taste yeah yeah yeah no okay
so one like when the characters are used
to like are still like oh my god i'm
tripping everywhere
when she talks about anime guys right
how am i shaking
oh my god um
so sorry
his color's orange everything about him
is orange she smells orange and
sometimes you know
or if he's eating an orange
and you know you just want to know what
they're eating and
no yeah yeah yeah so
does he canonically smell like oranges
no no
she said the weirdest thing to me right
because she was talking about her
obsession with uh 2d anime guys right
and she was just like did you ever like
did you ever see like a waifu or like
one of your waifus and you saw them
drinking something and you wanted to
drink the same thing and i was just like
uh no why did why did you want to do
that and i just thought i just thought
so you could taste what they're tasting
right and she goes to me uh yeah because
they just sometimes just want to know
what the inside of their mouth feels
like
[Laughter]
if you were a guy and you said that
everyone would be like you would be
immediately killed
what a pathetic man what a what a what a
good man is that correct what you said
or sometimes have like you know
commercials in japan where that
character is endorsing this and then you
drink it too and then you always think
about them because they're that's what
they're drinking in
does your husband feel like he's
competing sometimes no
no
well like i was also in long distance
with my
husband boyfriend at the time so like he
would drink coffee and then i'll be like
oh every time i drink coffee it's kind
of like
you kissing
[Laughter]
finish finish the sentence finish the
sentence it's not so much kissing as
it's more tasting the inside no no every
time he pees i pee it's like where it's
like
it's like we're crossing streams
yeah but like if someone's single and
they really like 2d characters
and you see your 2d character eating a
cake or something i definitely recommend
it it's called immersion
who are watching this and they're
drinking coffee too it's the same oh no
never mind
he's
she said to you on your birthday what
did he say to me sydney and sydney told
me
well mark you said oh i'm glad someone
understands or something
uh what
do you know my husband yeah of you yeah
like oh i'm glad oh yeah
i'm glad i found someone because uh both
our partners are crazy
they were they were just sitting next to
each other i think you were in the
corner somewhere having like a brochure
yeah
i gotta come clean man yeah and they
started laughing out loud and i was like
wonder whether because sydney sydney and
mainland hang out all the time and
sometimes it's just like it's it's just
like
too like it's just like the perfect
storm you know in the perfect song where
you have like two hurricanes and they
mix and then like forms
one super massive hurricane that's just
whenever sydney and me they hang
together
they just feed off each other's like
chaotic energy and they just like start
saying the most like cursed [ __ ] you'll
ever hear something
your husband would be like she's crazy
he just says that so that you think he's
normal too maybe maybe yeah
that is true yeah
is she still addicted to apex oh yes
did you ever say that no i haven't told
this oh yeah oh my gosh
i don't know we were at your we were at
baylene's house having a gathering yeah
yeah it was like two it was after i
think you went home yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah jojo yeah so i think it was
actually my birthday yeah it was my
birthday
because a lot of things happen there so
joey had to go home early because he had
to film the next day yeah um so we're at
mainland um i guess just chilling until
like 2 4 a.m yeah um i remember i
remember at 2 am i'm just like having a
chat with maelyn um and then i look over
and [ __ ] connor is like connor takes
the controller off maylin's husband and
she's like you need to play this game he
downloads downloads apex for maki and
i'm just like oh [ __ ] yeah he plays
every day i spent like you've poisoned
the world
i went to his house get the ps5 i
installed apex i was like wait now we'll
have so much fun he was showing me these
games on ps5 and i'm like this is
terrible these games are terrible let me
show you a real game it's free to
download let me download it right now i
downloaded it and then i i just thought
that maybe
he would play it a few times and then be
done but he's like addicted yeah he
plays every day every day
and i'll be in a call and he doesn't use
his like headphones so the walls
and i'm just like
i'm so sorry sorry that's just the ak-47